first of all let's talk about how much
fun it is to get dressed for the kid's
choice
um we were just saying how much fun you
get to have you're gonna do like
something a little out of the box a
little different i get to feel a little
young and hip right i wanted to bring
share vibes she brought like one
stephanie phil yeah i love it the 90s
all right here oh you guys nailed it and
you have having fun with the eye makeup
as well oh yes right yeah i told i
didn't want to say like a julia fox but
i feel like i kind of have a julia fox
going on kitty uncut
jumps you guys look amazing okay
obviously the kids choice awards is all
about celebrating kids what does it feel
like to be here especially being moms
yourselves you know it's really good
energy it's like when you go to
disneyland right it's like just really
fun and happy and that's how it felt so
i was i told bria i was like bri you
should bring birdie because this is
probably the most fun out of any carpet
and she was going to but i just the kids
energy like you said and then they get
so excited when people get slimed and i
do too i'm hoping it's not me today
are you prepared
are you are you either of you prepared
to be slime or is this the only outfit
you brought actually it's the only
outfit we brought yeah but back out in
robes if it happened guys i've been
slimed before well many times i feel
like so i'm always prepared free it
sounds like it's your turn i know i'm
really nervous now as long as i don't
get slimed like katy perry did that one
year a wig almost flew off i mean these
are accessories
someone told me you have to shuffle
after you get slimed to avoid falling
like katy perry wow i mean i'll probably
be cr like crawling and screaming for
help well it reminds me of the stingray
shuffle you know when you go in the
ocean and you do yeah yeah
but if there's anyone who knows how to
take a hit it's youtube yeah we would
make it look good and then we take on
the slime and be the first time they'd
ever see a match the bellas versus slime
you know what i mean really in the ring
now
um speaking of booking i gotta talk to
you guys about dancing with the stars
moving to disney plus like what did you
guys make of that move i was shocked
yeah i i was shocked too especially
because i saw it on online on social
media and i was immediately like arnhem
you're going to disney plus
so i don't
i don't know it's you know what i also
feel bad just for the viewers who can't
afford streaming services and i feel
like dancing was such an outlet for
people to enjoy with the family so as
long as it's still really good for
dancing because that's for my fiance you
know i hope it's the best i also think
it's cool they're doing history by being
the first live on streaming so it can
actually in the end open up a lot of
doors
maybe a mickey mouse
my god you will compete
they should like have different disney
characters frozen marvel you could do
marvel things yeah there you go star
wars could be pretty iconic that's true
do you want to see arm dressed up like
chewbacca and dancing with the stars
yeah and by the way he would be obsessed
because he's obsessed with star wars we
literally have disney plus to watch all
mandalorian everything yeah it might be
destiny it might be that's true um okay
so i have to get everyone's reaction to
bennefer being engaged ben and jen i
mean for the second time around it's
kind of special though right it is i
told you this morning yeah reaction yeah
i mean i was a little surprised i was
shocked too
a little bit with a lot of shockingness
there was a lot of news getting thrown
at me this morning um
no i think it's amazing and i look at
them they're a beautiful couple um i
just feel like it was just so recent
that her and a-rod had just split so i'm
like whoa this happened fast but when
you fall in love and you fall hard you
can't ever put time on that so it's a
beautiful thing yeah but they've already
been there so that's why i think it's
it's meant to be fast because they were
already engaged and i like that it's
again and she i think she really has
found her forever and she's so
comfortable she seems really happy i
just hope she has a wedding because i
need to see jayla's wedding dress we
deserve it
i have a question for you who do you
think is going to make it down the aisle
first bennefer or nicki and artem
jennifer
do you agree with that or do you think
you'll be better
i mean
i do i think we'll be beneficial don't
make me slime you right now don't make
me slime you for that
i don't know j-lo i mean she's run many
times so i think i might beat benefir we
deserve to see your wedding as well and
your wedding dress moment that is very
true yeah i want that moment i really do
what's gonna happen sooner or later you
know